[Music]  I'm Commander Cody your new boss so yes  looks like we got ourselves a batch of  Shaunie's commander just when hope was  all but lost Star Wars the Clone Wars is  coming back look around well one of the  same same hot same blood your training  is in your blood boiling for a fight  this jaw-dropping announcement just  happened over at comic-con in this  sneaky non halt age panel that was kind  of disguised as a reflective 10-year  anniversary of the series that was  unceremoniously canceled in 2013 all  right Rex what's so important that you  brought us all the way back here now we  don't know much more than this but we do  know there are 12 new episodes coming  straight to the direct-to-consumer  streaming service hello master it's been  a while